chargeham
Allah.
Allah
for
each turn your own.
is safe.
Alhamdulillah.
Then the im of
he mentions this following principle
concerning that which is related to the
rulers and that is the compulsory nature
of a semi of hearing and obeying the
rulers to hear and obey in that which
allahel loves and is pleased
He said that here he clarifies that
which is related to
to hearing and obeying the ruler even if
they are oppressive. And that is from
the fundamental principles that
I believe in and from the determining
factors and the distinguishing
characteristics of sunnah that
distinguish them from the people of
innovation and that is they believe in
the affair of obeying the ruler.
as opposed to that which
are upon.
They hold the permissibility or in fact
the compulsory nature of obeying the
ruler and this is indicated by the book
and by the sunnah and by and consensus
of the self of this um Huh?
What is
to sit down.
for
Now I mean so he mentions then that when
he [clears throat] discusses the
statement that whoever becomes a khalifa
for the consensus of the people and
their being pleased with him then he's
the chief of the believers. Here he
discusses one of the methods of uh
ascending to leadership and to rule and
that is uh that a person
receives what is known as
that he is selected by the khalifa to
become the following khalifa
and uh if there is a consensus of the
people that he is the one that is in
charge after such and such then he
becomes the khalifa
And that is in essence what was
indicated by the statements of the
prophet wasallam when he spoke of Abu
Bakr
that the prophet wasallam he said
Abu Bakr and in some narrations
uh that allahel has refused except Abu
Bakr and and that the people have
refused except Abu Bakr and that the
prophetam commanded that Abu Bakr be the
one that leads the people in salah. And
so all of these texts that speak of Abu
Bakr
have in them an indication of the fact
that he was the one that was selected to
be the Khalifa after the messenger of
Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Likewise, another method from the
methods of selecting the ruler and
selecting the Khalifa is
and that is that the choice returns back
uh to the uh people of discernment to
select their ruler, the ruler that is to
come after them. And so if it is clear
that there is unity upon him being the
ruler and the people have uh reached
something of an agreement upon him then
it is waj to hear and to obey.
There is likewise that which is related
to a person becoming the ruler by way uh
of overpowering the previous ruler. If
that occurs
and
uh they have unity that he is now the
new leader even though he overpowered
as long as they unite upon the fact that
he is the new ruler then he is the one
that hearing and obeying is to be given
to.
Muslim.
>> [clears throat]
>> Likewise,
he mentioned that it is not permissible
for a person to believe that or to spend
a single night believing that he has no
imam over him. Whether that im be
righteous or wicked, it is not
permissible to do so. Then whosoever
does so then uh he his death if he dies
in that state his death is a death ofah.
It is established in the
prophetam he said that whsoever dislikes
from his leader any anything then let
him be patient and he should not take
his hand away from obedience.
And so the establishment of obedience to
the im to the im the one who established
as the im is and is compulsory upon uh
the believer
for
you. for you.
We love you.
of
likewise
that which is related to the Hajj and
the Omrah the Hajj and the jihad
and the origin is that the Hajj and the
jihad
is done behind the ruler even if he is
an oppressive ruler
and one does not leave Allah making
jihad behind him if he's the ruler and
commands with that and he does not leave
alone on the Hajj and the performance of
Hajj behind him.
Even if the the ruler is one that is
a transgressor and an oppressive ruler.
Similarly, that which is mentioned
concerning salah and praying behind him
that one phrase the salah behind him
since in those days it was ordinarily
the imam who led the salah who led the
prayer for those prayers that he
mentions here. Yeah. The Juma prayer and
yeah in some instances the mention of
Eid that one prays behind them and he
does not repeat the salah and some
whosoever repeats the salah then he's
from the or considered from the
considered from the people of
innovation.
for
I give you.
the knowledge of
You can't.
He then mentions that which is related
to the salah or the salah that is
performed after salah
and the fact that the people of
knowledge there is something of a
difference of opinion around how much is
to be performed after
some of the scholars the first of the
physicians mentioned some of the
scholars mentioned
that is two that are per performed after
and that was a position of Abdahb
He likewise mentioned the position of
the and the majority and that is that
for to be performed and this position
was established upon
and it was a position of the majority of
the
likewise
from among the scholars were those who
held that one is mal that is you have a
choice are performing either two or four
and this was the position of Imam Ahmed.
Uh then we had those who in relation to
this two or four position
who held that if one is going to return
home and pray at home then he prays two
while if he remains in the masid then he
prays four and this was the position of
the likes of
and likewise
and then from those great scholars were
those who held that one performed Six
and this was the position of imbari
himself.
He rejected the fact that six is
established upon the messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. And that
which is most correct and gathers all of
these positions is that a person has uh
the option to perform any of the above
two or four or six uh and that one is
not restricted in relation to the
performance of that salah after
>> but if one were was to restrict oneself
to two or four knowing that that is
where the text lie that is of was best.
foreignch.
Now then mentions that which is related
to the
and that is that the will remain within
Quraysh until the descent of
the will remain among the Quraysh the
tribe of Buresh until
descends. That is uh until the coming of
the Mahi that it will continue to be the
case and that is based upon a number of
hadith numerous hadith that establish
the fact that will be among them such as
the statements of the messages sahamur
that the your leaders will be from among
or from
oh like the statement of the prophetam
that this affair will not cease being
among
As long as there remains two of them and
numerous other hadith that establish
that leadership remains among Quraysh as
long as there are individuals who are
fit to be leaders from them. It is
permissible for other than Qur to be to
be leaders. But if there has and if
there exists among Qur those who are fit
to be their to be leaders then they are
given priority in that regard. But if
for example uh their leadership were to
be taken from them or that they were to
be overpowered as may well occur and as
we've discussed previously uh if that
occurs then leadership uh is given to
the one who the people agree is now the
leader.
foreign.
He then likewise mentions that which is
related to the and the affair of the
and that wh who whomsoever rebelss
against a Muslim ruler is considered one
of the kawar and whom Whosoever rebelss
of the and this is from the from the
signs of the that is
revoling against the ruler and this is
done in one of two ways from those meth
methods and and manners he is fighting
against the ruler. Yeah.
expelling or rebelling against him by
fighting and through fighting against
him or it is done with the tongue and
that usually begins with making of the
ruler declaring him a non-Muslim. Yeah.
Islam.
So he mentions that it is not
permissible to fight against uh the
Muslim ruler even if he oppresses.
And so he mentions that it is not from
the sunnah to fight against the sultan
that it is not from the sunnah uh to
wage war against the ruler. For indeed
this is uh from the affairs that uh it
is no doubt that it is not established
upon any of the earlier that they would
do so. He mentions that it is neither
permissible to fight the ruler or to
rebel against him even if he oppresses.
And it is due to the statement of the
prophet in the abari.
have patience even if he is an
abbisoninian slave and until you meet me
upon uh the how for indeed there is no
fighting against the ruler in the sunnah
since it causes destruction of the
religion and worldly affairs and that is
established upon uh many of the people
of knowledge that never did this occur
except that it caused destruction in the
religion and destruction of the affairs
of the dunya
foreign.
for
the Quran.
Uh he mentions that it is permissible to
fight against the kawar if they attack
the person's property or families of the
Muslims but if they desist and flee then
they may not be chased nor are they
wounded to be killed nor sit upon
Nor may their may they be taken captives
or they those taken as captives be
killed. Uh nor are those who flee to be
followed. And this is a completion of
that which is related to fighting
against the and that is uh even though
the prophet mentioned that indeed I
would certainly fight against them
with the fighting of or the destruction
of
uh it is still not permissible if they
were to flee. is not permissible to
pursue them. It is not permissible to
take their their uh or those who have
been taken as captive as prisoners of
war. it is not permissible uh to yeah
any set upon them or to take their
property and other than that uh so what
we have then is the fact that what
clearly is taken from this and is in
this is indicative of is the fact that
is greater than sin because when it came
to the ruler that is the the the
oppressive ruler then the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam prescribed
and made mention of the fact that one
should be patient with him even if he
takes your wealth and beats you back
when it comes to the ruler.
Why? Because the oppressive ruler is a
person
of sin.
While the
the prophet wasallam did not prescribe
this patience with them. Rather he
prescribed that they should be fought
against and that if he was present when
they make themselves apparent that he
would fight against them with the
killing of which indicates that they are
greater in sin
and greater in evil than uh those who
commit the sin such as uh the oppressive
ruler. And so if they run away, if they
commit a sin, the Kawar is they're not
pursued. They are not taken in captives
as prisoners of war. And other than
that, from the things that ordinarily
take place with those who are fought
against, you know,
Then he mentions one of the important
principles related to the ruler and that
is that there is no obedience to the
creation if it necessitates disobedience
to the creator. And then this is a uh
and a reputation against those who claim
that the people of Sunnah are when it
comes to obedience to the ruler that we
obey the ruler regardless. It doesn't
matter what they do. We love the rulers
and we just obey them. This is a
reputation of that since the origin is
there is no obedience to the creation if
it necessitates disobedience to the
creator and that is the case here. If
they are disobedient and command with
disobedience, we're not obedient to
them. And so in that is a response to
this false claim.
foreign
for
open.
Now he mentions here then that which is
related to bearing witness that a person
is a person of the paradise or the
hellfire that we do not bear witness for
any person from the people of Islam that
he is in paradise or in the hellfire due
to a good or bad deed since we do not
know what their final action before his
death will
And that is the position of
that is this masah or this issue of
passing a verdict upon an individual
that he is in the hereafter either from
the people of Jenna or the people of the
na for indeed this masah and this issue
requires something of a clarification.
He said that the shahada that or bearing
witness that a person generally bearing
witness that a person is from the people
of good or from the people of evil uh is
upon based upon that which is apparent
is permissible. So it is permissible to
bear witness that a person is either
from the people of or from the people of
based upon what is what is apparent that
is permissible. As far as bearing
witness that a person is in the ja or in
the n, then this is where we refrain and
this is what is not permissible and we
hold that it is not possible for us to
bear witness to a person with ja or n
since we do not know what his final
actions will be. what will be sealed for
him in terms of his fate in the so
bearing witness to that which we see
apparently from good or evil is one
thing and then declaring him from the
people of Jenna or is another now
for
similarly he mentions that indeed
allahel accepts the repentance of all
sins and there is no sin except that the
serpent may repent from it. That is the
position of
Then whosoever makes Toba and returns to
Allahawel after committing a sin
regardless of the sin. And whosoever
makes Toba, Allahel will accept that
from him. And he mentioned the statement
of Allahel.
Say, "Oh my servants who have wronged
themselves and transgressed against
themselves, do not give up hope in the
mercy of Allah. Indeed allahel will
forgive all sin.
was
added
Allah.
Now then he mentions that indeed the
stoning is true and correct.
As far as is concerned, he mentioned
that indeed this is something that is
established and was mentioned here
because the Kawaris used to reject that
is the stoning of a man or a woman to
death. The Kawaris used to reject that
and they used to hold that this was not
something that was established returning
back to the same origin that was
mentioned previously. But the prophetam
had ma is stoned or the
uh that those who fornicated from among
the yahood had them stoned and likewise
the
is something that is established in the
sunnah and it was in actuality from
those things that were recited from the
Quran and he mentioned that these
messiah these issues when they are
related to fick they are connected to
the fact that from the people of
innovation were those who used to oppose
ose the sunnah in relation to them. And
so the scholars of the Sunnah would
mention them within these books in order
uh to deal with and discuss the fact
that from the people from the people of
innovation were those who opposed like
foreign.
for
Allah.
Allah
I don't know.
Now then went on to mention that which
is related to wiping over the suck and
that is that it is establishing the
sunnah to wipe over the suck and this is
from the messiah
from the issues related to Jewish
prudence. The people of innovation
differed in relation to yeah and it
differed from the sunnah and those who
differed in this regard in in relation
to the wiping over the saka the likes of
the uh
and they differ in from two main angles
from one angle the issue of wiping
itself and another angle from the issue
of the definition of the cab.
As far as the affair of wiping then they
hold the permissibility or they hold
that the foot is wiped over. And from
the angle of the definition of the cab
of the ankle they say that uh the ankle
or the intent behind the cab is the
place where the strap of one's sandals
gather. And thus they wipe over the top
of the foot because they claim that that
is the cab the place where the strap of
one's sandals gather together and join
uh and so they differ in relation to the
wiping itself and they wash and they
differ in relation to where they claim
the place of wiping is and likewise of
course they utilize discussion revolves
around the ayah itself
with and
with with fat. As far as those uh who
hold
then they say that this is a reference
to wiping over the the
uh there is an issue because
grammatically uh the ayah mentioned
which indicates that it is connected to
those things that are washed previously.
Allah mentioned
the indicates that that is the thing
that the action is done to
your arms, your hands to the elbow.
Then
so this is a reference to the wiping.
Then Allah mentions
back to fatha which means just as those
limbs previously had fath because the
washing applies to them. The foot
likewise has fath because washing
applies to it. That is the origin. But
there is a and there is a recitation
that mentions
which would indicate that it is white
just as the head is white. But here the
scholars mention it is white if the hof
is upon it. And so if one recites with
the kas that is if one is wearing the
hoof if one recites on its origin which
with fata is clearly that it is washed.
So there isn't an issue as it relates to
understanding uh the ayah.
Okay.
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
and then he mentions that which is
related to the affair
of from the sunnah being the shortening
of the prayer while journeying or while
traveling. Uh and so this issue then is
as it relates to the prayer of the and
the one who is traveling it is
established in the sunnah uh that uh the
one who is upon a journey it is
permissible for him to shorten the
prayer uh if he is a upon a journey as
allahel mentions uh then there is no
harm upon you
that you shorten the prayer uh as occurs
in the ayah and Likewise uh the
statement of the prophetam
it is a charity that allahel has given
to you. So accept the charity of Allah.
Likewise
uh that which is established from the
statement of the prophet wasallam.
Whoever wills or whoever wishes may fast
and whoever wishes may break their fast.
Uh and uh so that which we have likewise
is light to the statement of allahel
whoever is sicker upon a journey than a
number of other days. And so this affair
shortening the salah or breaking the
fast these will return back in essence
to an issue the issue of mash difficulty
or the absence of difficulty. If there
is difficulty then what is best is to
take the allowance. But if there is the
absence of difficulty then uh one may uh
carry out or continue with the fast. But
the issue is what is better? Is it
better to fast or is it better to break
the fast? Oh mentioned that what
what is most clear is that fasting is
that is it is clearer in fulfilling that
which is upon an individual. If you fast
there is nothing to make up. If you
decide to fast then there is nothing for
you to make up. If you were to die at
that time there would be nothing on your
head. And so it is clearer and better
for having a clear uh conscience that
has nothing bound by way of the actions
upon it.
You shall
be okay.
Again [clears throat]
he mentions here and praying there is no
harm in praying whilst wearing broad and
loose trousers.
He said and that is as long as the
individual has his shoulder covered as
long as his shoulders are covered it's
permissible to pray in the saw or the
broad fitting trousers and this is an
issue that has was raised because of the
fact that the
and others from among the people of
innovation they held that it wasn't
permissible to pray in the
and because of the permission or the
position that they held in relation to
praying In we have the likes of these
issues mentioned in these books of and
these books of sunnah. Why? Because
these people oppose the sunnah in
relation to them that you can't pray in
them. And so the people of sunnah the
sunnah would mention them in these books
highlighting that it was only the people
of innovation that held these positions
now.
for
and then he mentions that hypocrisy
is to display Islam with the tongue
while inwardly hiding disbelief. Here he
mentions that which is related to and
the fact that
is of two types mentions
which is or hypocrisy of the heart and
that is the the the hypocrisy of the
like those at the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam those
hypocrites who made hidden or had hidden
while making Islam apparent. He said and
from the forms of is
that is the of action and that is that a
person displays the of the he displays
the of the hypocrite
and that then does not exit a person
from Islam. The first category does the
first category if he displays this type
of he's outside of Islam while the
second category it is the or the
character of the and he's not outside of
Islam if he does so now
Now then he mentions that the world is a
place of im that is that the world is a
place of im that the world is a place
for that a person is bound by the and
that is that the rulings of the of the
are placed upon him in the as far as
reward and what have you then that
occurs in
The is a place of from being bound by
the carrying out actions.
Muslim.
Now then he mentions that which is
related to the fact that the there are
believers and Muslims among the nation
of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and among the nation of Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam there are
believers and Muslims with regard to
rulings, inheritance, slaughtering
animals and the funeral prayer. That is
to say uh the um of Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam are those who have
within them or manifest these mis
affairs
as the prophetam uh uh or prior to that
which indicates is taking people upon
what is apparent and that is a principle
in our dean that we take people upon
that which is apparent as prophetam said
whomsoever prays our prayer faces ourlah
and eats our slaughtered meat then he is
the believer Then this is the believer.
And so the uh the principle here is that
whomsoever manifests Islam that it is
upon what is apparent. We take him upon
that which is apparent. Now
foreign.
Amen.
He mentions here and we do not bear
witness uh that any of them is a true
and perfect believer. Unless he fulfills
all of the laws and the duties of Islam
and if he neglects any of that then his
iman is deficient until he repents.
his iman is for Allah the most high
alone to judge whether it is complete or
incomplete to the end of that passage he
said that this then is or this statement
is uh the establishment of the fact that
a person or we do not bear witness to
any individual
uh except that uh to any individual who
falls into a sin or a major sin or an
error. We do not say that he exites
exits Islam rather we say that he is or
that he is deficient in im on the basis
of doing so or that he is a
he's a with his im but a with the action
or the major sin that he has carried out
and so in this is a reputation against
the those who say that sin do not affect
a person and in it is likewise a
reputation against Those
who say that the one who commits a sin
then he leaves Islam. No.
forch.
So he mentioned similarly uh that it is
sunnah to offer the funeral prayer upon
anyone who dies from the people of the
kibla, whether an adulterer or
adulteress stoned to death and the one
who commits suicide other than and
others from the people of the kibla and
the drunkard and other than them to pray
the funeral prayer over them is sunnah.
Shik mentioned that this salah is salah
upon the one who dies from the people of
the Gibla. Whether an adulterer or
adulteress or one who dies while drunk
or one who has taken a life that one
prays is upon them or upon that
individual and that salah remains.
It may be that the imam who is respected
and has position that he may leave salah
upon the individual in order to warn
against this type of action. And so this
would be done out of what is known as
za. And the prophetam left alone for
example salah on someone who stole from
the spores of war. Uh but the prophetam
prayed over the woman from the tribe who
was stoned for fornication.
And so the affair then returns back to
the fact that regardless of the action
that they have performed, salah is to be
done and to be performed over them. Now
So we stop and we'll uh pause at that
point.
There is a uh a requestwan
uh when the brothers leave the masid
that you try not to gather outside of
the masid or to raise voices outside of
the masid. uh since we're still in a
residential uh neighborhood, a
residential community and just as it is,
believe it or not, back home, we have it
in the lands of the Muslim uh as well.
Just as we have problems with the
neighbors and people who complain, we
likewise have it here. And of course,
when we have our mash from the mash of
the sunnah, there are individuals who
may have some issues or may wish and
desire to raise some issues against our
mash. So please be careful not to cause
a nuisance, not to raise your voices
when you leave. If you have transport,
jump in your transport
and get off.
Leave as swiftly as possible without
without noise in Juan.
We don't want to create any problem for
our here in in the uh uh in the area.